ja wir müssen wieder anfangen mit ganz
aktuellen Bildern aus Kiew heute morgen
dort schwere Explosionen hier im Norden
der Stadt und wir müssen wissen
mittlerweile dass die russische Armee
heute morgen bis zu 50 Raketen und
Marschflugkörper auf die Ukraine
geschossen hat angeblich zu sagen die
Ukraine haben Sie davon 44 abgefangen
dennoch schwere Schäden im ganzen Land
wir haben in Kiew Angriffe und wieder
hat es eben die kritische Infrastruktur
getroffen nämlich
Wasserkraftwerke waren wohl heute das
Ziel nicht nur in Kiew sondern auch
entlang des genannten gesamten Flusses
der Turnier wir gucken uns das gleich
einmal an hier sehen wir aus der Stadt
cremenschuk auch am die nähere Szenen wo
eben das
das Wasserkraftwerk dort brennt
es ist wieder das gleiche Muster was wir
schon den letzten Wochen erlebt haben
nachdem die Ukraine als geschafft haben
am Wochenende ja ein russisches
Kriegsschiff anzugreifen vor der
besetzten Krim scheint sich die großen
jetzt dafür zu rächen und greifen hier
wieder an wir sehen aber auch dass die
Ukrainer können wir es einige der
Raketen abgeschlossen haben hier sehen
wir eine Flugabwehrrakete unter
Umständen vom deutschen iris-t-system
was über Kiew aufsteigt und jetzt hier
explodiert und eine weitere Rakete
abfängt und am Ende sehen wir noch mal
wo zwar das ganze geführt nicht nur noch
zur Stromausfällen sondern das sind
Aufnahmen aus einem Kira vor Ort es gibt
kein Wasser mehr und wir wissen vom
Kiefer Bürgermeister Vitali Klitschko
mittlerweile das 80% der Hauptstadt ohne
Strom und ohne Wasser sind so extrem
also die Folgen der russischen Angriffe
dort wir schauen uns das ganze noch mal
ganz kurz auf der Karte an und sehen
dass hier saporisha hier die Pro hier
cremenschuk und hier oben auch Kiew
getroffen wurde aber und das ist
interessant auch der Westen der Ukraine
wurde heute morgen angegriffen und die
Ukraine hat diesen marshmallow-körper
abgeschossen und der ist in Moldawien
abgestürzt das heißt es hat faktisch
einen russischen Angriff heute auf
Moldawien gegeben auch dort gab es
mehrere oder gab es schwere Feuer und
gab es auch Schäden
wir schauen uns den Osten des Landes an
und dort in der Stadt bachmut gehen
diese schweren Kämpfe weiter wir wissen
in vielen Teilen des Landes ist so dass
das eben die Ukraine am Vormarsch sind
dass sie auch moderne Waffen einsetzen
im Bach mut ist es ganz anders dass es
die Stadt die eben von den Russen vor
allem von den Wagner söldern versucht so
zu erobern und wir haben hier Szenen das
wurde jetzt von verschiedenen Experten
gesagt wie im ersten Weltkrieg das
erinnert an die Schlacht von war da wir
sehen uns das ganze mal an von einem
vulkanischen Soldaten hier diese
Aufnahmen der sitzt hier im Graben ja
und wartet quasi auf die Russen wir
sehen das außenrum die ganzen Bäume all
ihre Blätter verloren haben die
Artillerie hat dort alles abgerissen wir
sehen was um ihn rum sind für Waffen
nämlich einmal sein schweres
Maschinengewehr aus Italien
interessanterweise das ganze gesponsert
aber eben auch jetzt gleich zu sehen
Handgranaten und Handgranaten zeigen
eben schon dass da sehen wir es hier
sind die Handgranaten hier über mir
rumliegen dass ihr damit rechnet dass er
die Russen auf ja 10 15 Meter Entfernung
bekämpfen muss und wir sehen jetzt auch
gleich weiter was eben da ist also er
hat dieses Maschinengewehr hier fest im
Griff und wir sehen dann gleich weiter
das von Panzerfäusten von alten RPG 7
hier die die Geschosse liegen auch die
nur auf 50 Meter einzusetzen und was wir
nicht gezeigt haben in diesem Video und
was extrem grausam ist ist das wenige
Meter vor dem Graben die Russen
tatsächlich liegen da liegen tote Russen
die können nicht rausgeholt werden weil
die Ukrainer natürlich nicht rauskommen
können weil sie dann von den Russen
erwischt werden und die Russen auch ihre
Toten hier nicht zurückholen können so
also die Situation im Osten des Landes
es erinnert tatsächlich in einigen
Teilen dort eben an den Ersten Weltkrieg
wo ja in vadan zwei 1916 sich über
Monate dort deutsche Truppen und
französische gegenüberstanden bis dann
die deutschen den Angriff aufgegeben
haben zu hoffen bleibt dass es auch
irgendwann hier in bachmut der Fall ist
seit Monaten versuchen die Russen davor
zu bringen sie haben die Stadt nicht
erobert aber direkt davor wird eben
weiter in den Gräben erbittert gekämpft
[Musik]